oh it's pet adoption week here welcome  back and our dog today is  rhino who's with the spca of  dallas texas look at him no  he's a two and a half year old mixed  breed and reiner rhino is a fighter he  was found  malnourished and without a coat but look  at him now  he's incredible and he's looking for a  family who's ready to play with him  so potential adopters go to spca.org  dog adopt for more info on rhino and  other pets  in the dex dallas texas area douglas  what do you think do you like rhino  i like rhino i adopted um douglas when  he was eight weeks old and that was 12  years ago  in northern like hollywood  and my whole life has been so much  [Music]  better  you